avec sa croûte fleurie ses arômes de
noisette et son cœur crémeux c'est la
pyramide la plus célèbre de la Braine
bah c'est un fromage de chèvre très
agréable en plus il a un goû vraiment
spécial sur le marché du
blanc ça c'est
Pini le poulini saint-pierre c'est plus
qu'un fromage c'est presque une religion
même 4 He je peux mettre petite tranche
de pain morceau de pouli
pour percer ses secrets il faut se lever
tôt comme
wifal he début de la traite quotidienne
de ces 130
chè qu Mme
70 pour lui femme van l'élevage n'ait
pourant rien d'évident c'est en 2012
qu'il décide de quitter le monde du
commerce pour se
lancer vu qu'on est dans le milieu dans
la région du de la chèvre des AOP ça
semblait naturel de venir ici une fois
la traite terminée la suite se passe
dans le
laboratoire le lait est mélanger à de la
présure pour former après 24 heures de
patience le
cahier de lait il est passé en gros
fromage blanc en
fait il est ensuite placé dans ses
moules bien rempli pour être égoûté
pendant 24 heures encore et lui donner
enfin sa fameuse forme pyramidale dont
l'origine reste un
mystère ça part d'une légende
apparemment il a été copié du clocher de
l'église de poulini Saint-Pierre ça
viendrait de là mais quand on regarde
historiquement le clocher en fait il a
pas cette forme là direction ensuite le
séchoir avant de terminer la
transformation dans le hoir c'est ici
que va se développer la croûte blanche
du poulini et son goût doux est crémeux
leur fromage Wilfried et Vanessa ont
choisi de ne pas le commercialiser en
supermarché il est vendu autour de 4,50
€ dans un réseau de petite fromagerie ou
directement à laffireme 2550 s'il vous
plaît
5 retour sur le marché du blanc avec le
chef Frédéric Berto le poulini des
recettes de son restaurant il va le
chercher chez Patricia fourand qu'il
connaît depuis l'enfance tu peux me
donner tris po
trois fromages en poche direction son
restaurant à quelques kilomètres de là
pour une recette avec un poisson des
étant alentours filet de carpe ça va
être la base de notre plat avec du
poulini bien sûr du 100 % local toutes
les saisons on essaie de de trouver bah
une nouvelle idée pour pour voilà pour
présenter nos produits is de notre
territoire la carpe hachée revenue avec
un consommé de tomates et des épices va
venir farcir des canélonis qui seront
ensuite recouvert de poulini ah bah
toute la crème l'onctuosité voilà ça va
contrebalancer notre partie dessous qui
est acide c'est pour ça qu' on a associé
un fromage avec surtout polinier qui est
très crémeux 10 minutes au four
suffiront pour gratiner le tout et
charmer les papis des
clients moi c'est la première fois que
je mange du fromage de poulini avec du
poisson et c'est comment bah c'est
[Musique]
le fait de le mettre avec de l'associer
avec la carpe c'est qui est normalement
un peu F carp seul l'association des
deux c'est excellent le pouini
saint-pierre bénéficie d'une appellation
d'origine protégée depuis 2009 pour
préserver le savoir-faire autour de ce
monument de la gastronomie berichon